you have eight coins in a bag three of
them are unfair in that they have a 60%
chance of coming up heads when flipped
the rest are fair coin so if three are
unfair the rest are eight coins when I
say that or when this problem says that
they are fair coins it means that they
have a 50/50 chance of coming up either
heads or tails you randomly choose one
coin from the bag and flip it two times
what is the percent probability of
getting two heads so this is an
interesting question but if we break it
down essentially with the decision tree
it'll help break it down a little bit
better so let's say that so we have a
bag three of them are unfair so that we
can even visualize the bag you don't
have to do this all the time so we have
out of the fair coins and white one two
three four four five fair coins and we
have three unfair coins one two three
and this whole thing is my bag right
over here that is my bag of coins if I
were to when I take my hand in if I were
to take any of these white coins there's
a 50% chance that it gets heads on any
flip the odds of getting two heads in a
row would be 50% times 50% for these
white coins but I don't know I'm going
to get a white coin if I get the one of
these orange coins I have a 60% chance
of coming up heads and the odds of
coming up 60% if I if I have picked one
of these orange coins the probability of
getting heads twice is going to be 60
percent times 60% so how do I factor in
this idea that I don't know if I've
picked a white fair coin or an orange
unfair coin we will assume that the
coins actually aren't white Norns they
all look like regular coins so what I'll
do is I'll draw a little bit of a little
bit of a decision tree here I guess
maybe I could call it a probability tree
so there's some probability that I pick
a fair coin that I pick a fair coin and
there is some probability that I pick an
unfair coin unfair coin and so what is
the probability that I pick a fair coin
well 1 2 3 4 5 out of the total 8 coins
are fair
so there is a 5/8 probability there is a
5/8 I'll write here on the branch
actually so there's a 5/8 chance that I
pick a fair coin and then there is a 3 1
2 3 out of 8 chance that I pick an
unfair coin so if I were to just tell
you what's the probability of picking a
fair coin you'd say a 5/8 what's the
probability of an unfair coin 3/8 and
you could convert that to a decimal or a
percentage or whatever you'd like
now given that I have picked a fair coin
what is the probability that I that I
will get heads twice so let me write it
this way this is just notation right
here so the probability of I'll call it
heads heads so I get two heads in a row
given given that I have a fair coin
given that I have a fair coin it looks
like very fancy notation but just like
look if you knew for a fact that that
coin you had is absolutely fair that it
has a 50% chance of coming up heads what
is the probability of getting two heads
in a row well then we can just say well
that's just going to be 50% so 50% times
50% times 50% which is equal to 25%
which is equal to 25% now what is the
probability that you so if you want if
you want to know what is the probability
that you picked a fair coin and you got
two heads in a row so given that you
have a fair coin it's a 25% chance that
you have two heads in a row but the
probability of picking a fair coin and
then given the fair coin getting two
heads in a row will be the 5/8 times the
25% so the probability so this whole
branch I should maybe draw it this way
the probability of this whole series
events of happening so starting with you
picking the fair coin and then getting
two heads in a row will be I'll write it
this way it will be 5/8 5 over 8 times
this right over here times the 0.25
times 0.25 I want to make it very clear
the 0.25
probability of getting two heads in a
row given that you knew that you had to
get a you got a fair coin but the
probability of this whole series of
events happening you would have to
multiply this times the probability that
you actually got a fair coin so another
way of thinking about it is this is the
probability this is the probability that
you got a fair coin that you got a fair
coin and then you have two heads in a
row and that you have two heads in a row
now let's do the same thing for the
unfair coin
so the probability I'll do that in the
same green color the probability that I
get heads heads given that my coin is
unfair given that is unfair so if you
were to somehow know that your coin is
unfair what is the probability of
getting two heads in a row well in this
unfair coin it has a 60% chance of
coming up heads so it will be equal to
0.6 times zero point six which is 0.36
so if you have an unfair coin if you
know for a fact that you have an unfair
coin if that is a given you have a 36
percent chance of getting two heads in a
row now if you want to know the
probability of this whole series events
the probability that you picked an
unfair coin and and you get two heads in
a row so the probability of unfair
unfair and two heads in a row given that
you had that unfair coin you would
multiply this 3/8 times the 0.36 so this
will be equal to this will be equal to
the 3/8 this 3/8 times times 0.36 and so
let's get a calculator out and calculate
these so if I take 5/8 5/8 times 0.25 I
get 15-point or I'll just write it as a
decimal point one five six two five so
this is equal to zero point one five six
two five and
then if I do the other part so if I have
3/8 times 0.36 that gives me Oh point 1
3 5 so this is zero point 1 3 5 so if
someone were to ask you what's the
probability of getting a halving of
picking the fair coin and then getting
head two heads in a row with that fair
coin you would get this number if some
want to say what's the probability of
you pick the unfair coin and then get
two heads in a row with that unfair coin
you would get this number now if someone
were to say either way either way what's
the probability of getting two heads in
a row because that's what they're asking
us here what is the probability of
getting two heads so we could get it
through this method by chance picking
the fair coin or through this method by
chance picking the unfair coin so since
we can do it either way we can sum up
the probabilities either of these events
either of these events meet our
constraints so we can just add these two
things up so let's do that so we can add
0.135 plus 0.15 6 2 5 gives us point 2 9
1 2 5 so point 0 point 2 9 1 to 5 that's
when we add 0.15 6 to 5 plus 0 point 1 3
5 will equal this and if we want to
write it as a percentage you essentially
just multiply this times 100 and add the
percentage sign there so this is equal
to 29 point one two five percent or if
we were to round to the nearest
hundredths then this would be well this
would be the exact number or we could
say it's approximately 29 point one
three percent depending on how much we
need to round it so we have a little
less than a third chance of this
happening and the reason why remember if
it was a fair coin there was only B if
everything in the bag was a fair coin
there'd be a 25% chance of this
happening because you would just say
okay any of these they're all the same
flip it twice 25% chance our chance is a
little bit higher because there's some
probability there's a
a chance that we pick a coin that has a
higher than even chance of coming up
heads